hi everyone um i'm mo
and i'm really stoked to be here um
we're gonna try something a little bit
different tonight to kind of uh have a
proxy for what might happen in real life
which is at the beginning you kind of
walk in
you might talk to a few people you might
especially since there's two groups kind
of coming together you might say hey
which group are you coming from and in
order to proxy that
what we'll try to do is put everybody
into four breakout rooms with each of
the panelists
um and me and uh kind of chat
introduce ourselves just a little bit
and then we'll come back together and
kind of start the panel
from scratch with us introducing
ourselves uh more formally and then kind
of
roving through some different ethic
issues in
ethics how does that sound to to folks a
lot of people
don't have their cameras on but i
usually just give a thumbs up sometimes
awesome yay okay cool uh looking forward
to this experiment
thanks for for bearing with our uh
attempt to kind of foster community
worldwide maybe they're in zoom limbo
anyways um to get you kind of like to
let you all know how
kind of what we're hoping the flow of
the night's going to be is that
uh each of the panelists kind of has a
specialty or special interest within
ethics i think one thing that i just
want to emphasize before we
kind of go into the night uh based on
even
all the different interests that people
in my room had and like
what part of ethics they'd be interested
in hearing about is that
data and tech ethics or ai ethics is
a huge thing and so everybody that works
in it kind of focuses on
kind of a different aspect of it there's
some
basic principles that we'll particularly
focus on during the first part
but then beyond that some of the
applications of ethics really matter
based on your domain knowledge and
context-specific applications
and so just i want to start the panel a
little bit with kind of that in our
minds
and invite you all to kind of uh so we
can move beyond
both incorporate concepts like fairness
and bias
but then also uh move beyond that to see
what our
kind of own agency and power is within
kind of applying tax tech ethics to our
data work
and anyways cool with that in mind and
it's also good to see so many more
faces on video and i also totally
understand
if you're not putting on video because i
do that to you at the end of the day
um all right so i'm mo um i
have been in tennessee for the past
several months but i've been in san
francisco for
several years um my first part of my
career was actually in public health
uh so this current moment is really
relevant through public health i got
very interested in the different ways
that vulnerable groups were kind of
incorporated into data and research
when i moved to san francisco i got into
tech saw some of the same issues
got involved with tech ethics and then
now with cobed i'm figuring out ways to
combine those two so really
excited to be here and also meet all of
y'all which feels like kind of the uh
the nexus of some of like the health and
data community in the united states
as well i am joined by three amazing
panelists
uh a couple of them i've known a while
one of them i just met and it's been
wonderful
um all of them have kind of some
specialties that we're going to like
touch on
throughout the course of the talk and
then hopefully
throughout it will give you all
opportunities to ask some questions
uh we'll take a break right in the
middle and at the end we might go back
into breakout rooms uh
for any for more kind of uh
community-based
discussion so that's that's the plan
um i will let you all introduce yourself
uh we'll start with emily how does that
sound
sounds great uh hi everyone i'm emily
i'm
a senior data scientist at driven data
and driven data uh we are a data science
and machine learning consultancy in the
social good space
and so this means that we work with
non-profits and ngos research
organizations
uh socially minded private sector
companies to really help them use the
tools of data science and machine
learning to increase their impact
apart from our direct consulting work we
also devote some time to building open
source tools that let us give back to
the data science community
one of which is focused on data ethics
and so that's what i'm going to talk a
little bit more about today
we'll go with charlotte
hey everyone i'm charlotte i usually
hear pronouns i'm a data analytics
associate at the climate reality project
so right now i'm working on
using data and quantitative insight to
evaluate the impact of our climate
education programs and inform our
climate advocacy strategy
before getting really kind of deeply
into the climate space i worked on a
number of
applied community-based research and
data projects uh
including investigating community claims
of racial disparity in foster care
removals addressing
uh equity concerns and the provision of
homelessness services
and modeling member engagement in a
youth climate movement in addition to
some work with aclu of colorado
on um ending money bail practices and
minimizing the
uh realm of the cultural state so i'm
super passionate about
applied community-based data work and
i'm sure you'll hear a lot of examples
from each of those projects
later on tonight excited to get to talk
to everyone
awesome and now from pneuma
hi i'm nema i'm a data scientist at the
global disinformation index
where i work on detecting and
demonetizing the spread of online
disinformation
i have been in the disinformation space
for a couple years now so before this i
was working with new knowledge
now known as yonder and where a lot of
the work that i was doing
was detecting and understanding
influenced operation at scale
um i'm really excited to be here and
talk through some of the challenges
of working in a field as nuanced to ask
this information
and a lot of the ethical considerations
that come along with it
awesome thank you all for introducing
yourselves
um and i'm looking forward to get
started
we thought that the first thing we do is
start with the kind of most concrete
part of uh ethics within tech
and we're going to have emily introduce
a toolkit and use that as kind of a
focus
of how we kind of build up the
conversation from there
um we'll talk for about 20 minutes with
a few different questions and then open
it up for questions for
about 10 minutes feel free to either
type them in chat and we'll kind of keep
an eye on that if that's your preference
or if you'd rather
kind of in about 20 minutes maybe 15
ask a couple questions out loud to the
group then we'll be
happy to do that as well
all right emily i'll let you i'll let
you kind of show what what the
toolkit can do and then i'll have some
questions for all of us
awesome um so
great i'm in screen share in a bit but i
imagine people might have some
screen fatigue so i'm just going to talk
for a little bit to start
so as i said we've built an open source
tool focused on data ethics and it's
called dion
and what dion is it's this command line
tool that lets you
easily add an ethics checklist to your
data science projects
and so what we had seen is that a lot of
conversations about
uh data ethics and ethics and ai can be
relatively theoretical
and vague and they can remind us of the
importance of
data ethics but they don't often tell us
what we should be doing about it
right and so there's kind of this gap
between not wanting to do
harm right this idea of do no harm and
then actually
in practice like what does it look like
to be checking for different ways that
you could unintentionally
be causing harm uh and so that's why we
started thinking about like how can we
basically help data scientists
actionably engage with data ethics and
really integrate that
into our workflow because for a lot of
these things that seem like technical
questions
they actually have these big ethical
implications that we want to make sure
that we're spending time
to discuss excuse me um
we have a couple of people who are
trying to get into the meeting
ray light and oh my god
not entirely sure what that was about
you add that to the chat sorry
emily why don't you just add that into
the chat
all right cool so we'll continue on um
we can figure out waiting room stuff too
um great so getting back to dion
i'm to share my screen here just to help
make this a little bit more
concrete um so what i'm showing you here
this is the
home page dion.drivendata.org
which has all of the information that
you'll need so you can check this out
later but i just want to highlight
a few things here so first uh as i said
dion is this command line tool that lets
you add a checklist so
what does that actually look like so i
want to actually
start with the checklist um
to give you a sense of what we're
talking about here so the
ethics checklist is divided into five
sections
uh we have data collection data storage
analysis
modeling and deployment and this is
really
meant as a reasonable starting set of
questions
that can help us surface the different
ethical implications
that come up over the course of the data
science process this is not
intended to be the like be all and all
set of questions that will get you all
the answers this is meant as a
really helpful way to go from these kind
of big picture principles
into the questions that can help us have
these discussions that we need to have
on our teams
right and so when we think about data
ethics we want to remember that ethics
is hard it is nuanced right we expect
reasonable people to disagree and
oftentimes there's not
one right answer right and so a lot of
these questions when we start to look at
these and we
see things like collection bias like
have we considered sources of bias that
can be introduced data collection
during data collection or things like
proxy discrimination
like checking that the model doesn't
rely on unfair proxies for variables
these are not specific like remove
variable x from your model
right because it's it's not that simple
and so what this is intended to do
is to integrate these discussions into
the workflow
of the data scientist and so that's also
why
it's built as a command line tool right
so it's it's two lines to use it's
really straightforward you just hip
install it
and then you output the checklist you
can pass in a custom checklist if you
have other concerns that you want to
include
and the reason why we did this instead
of we could have just created a google
document and put the checklist there and
said hey guys here's a checklist
but it's really easy if to just forget
about that right it's now outside of the
project workflow
and so this ability to output the
checklist to a markdown format that then
you commit to your github repo
and you submit a pr and you use that to
start that discussion with your team
right you can output it to a jupiter
notebook and that makes it really easy
to engage with some of these questions
right right alongside the work that
you're actually doing right and so like
when you get into analysis
you have those reminders right and so
that's why we have this checklist
approach is that it's it's helpful at
translating these kind of big picture
ideas to everyday
tasks but also because it builds habits
right and so as you go through this and
it becomes part of your data science
process
the next time that you're working with a
new data set you kind of have these
things in the back of your head of like
oh but have i thought about what's not
in my data
and what happened in data collection
right
and so the the other thing i want to say
here
uh is about specific examples right so
this is
this is the tool right you can create
this checklist it helps
surface the considerations it helps
prompt those discussions it helps you be
intentional
in the choices that you're making um but
some of these can still feel a little
vague
right so let's get more specific so if
we take collection bias for example
um this question talks about have we
considered
the sources of bias that can be
introduced during data collection
and survey design and taken steps to
mitigate those
and so many of you would be familiar
that there's a lot of
research out there about designing
representative samples writing the stats
literature
um and that is important but that does
not mean that we don't have any
collection bias right because there are
things that we did not capture
in our survey right there are even ways
that we can
inadvertently introduce bias in our data
by the questions and the responses that
we ask
so if we ask people their gender and the
only responses are male and female then
we've now
inadvertently excluded the portion of
the population that identifies as
non-binary
so that's like when you think about
household survey data but we also have
this issue
with passively collected data and and
that
can be harder to spot but even more
important
and so to give you an example of what
collection bias can look like
in passive data collection i want to
talk about
uh street bump which is actually the
city of boston
uh uh worked to create this app
i'm in san francisco but i figured since
many of you are in boston to help
have a local example so the idea behind
the street bump app
was that it was going to use your
accelerometer and your gps data from
smartphones
to detect potholes uh and so on the
surface this seems like a great idea
right because we're using
possibly collected data we're not
bothering people we're understanding
where potholes are and we can make more
data driven
uh investments um and and fix fossils
more efficiently
but we need to think through right our
source of data collection is coming from
smartphones
and so who owns smartphones and who
doesn't
right and we and we know uh we know
things about the digital divide we know
that older populations are less likely
to own smartphones
uh this can also be the case for lower
income populations
and so by relying on smartphone data we
can end up with these
unfairly discriminatory resource
allocations where we end up fixing
potholes
in richer and younger areas not because
they have
more potholes but just because they have
more smartphones right and so this is
exactly the sort of thing that we want
to be thinking about
because there are various things that we
can do to address this we can bring in
additional data we can re-weight based
on census data right we can
research what that digital divide looks
like and use that to counter balance
data maybe we even need to like
supplement this and have additional
people drive around to neighborhoods
that we know are underrepresented
right and so there's there's not this
like excellent right answer and it's not
to say that street bump is a bad idea or
that using
passive data question is a bad idea it's
just understanding right like what are
we missing
what do we need to have um and and being
able to be intentional about that
thank you i i thanks for going over the
entire
uh for a lot of the checklists and that
specific example i think one thing that
strikes me about it and to open it up to
the all of the panel is that
one of the biggest questions i get
whenever i've worked with people kind of
on data projects on ethics is like where
to begin and this gives a very practical
built into the code way which i think is
is kind of amazing in a lot of ways
um i think what i'm curious about
focusing on a little bit and maybe a lot
of people here
are too is that and you touched upon
with kind of the data collection
is that once you introduce an ethical
question
does it fundamentally change the
analytical
results so like does it matter do ethics
matter and kind of the numeracy of like
what is going to happen
at different parts of the data life
cycle and
in your example i think specifically
with with gender
obviously it matters if you give a
binary and we don't live in a binary
or with street lamps um and or
sorry potholes not a city planner but um
the uh then there's different ways to
kind of
accommodate for and modify that um and
i'm curious uh newma and charlotte too
if there's any kind of work y'all have
done where that ethical consideration
actually changes
the analytical outcome in a way
i'll let you all kind of explore one of
you i'll explore that first and then
hear from the other
i can start off uh emily that was so
cool i'm
like hearing you walk through that and
give those examples i love all of your
proposals for like how to address that
um pothole because paul consideration uh
similarly uh in thinking about
collection bias
i work a lot with administrative or
passively collected data
and thinking about who is not in the
data and what activities are not in the
data
is everything to that work so as a part
of
only being able to access administrative
data i only have
say let's take the example of
understanding homelessness services
who's accessing services what do they
look like what communities do they come
from and how are the services working
for that we
only have data when people have made
contact with services
so if they find another way to improve
their situation
if they move out of the area we don't
have any information on their outcome so
trying to figure out what what
services are working for what
communities is really really complicated
as a task
and i think the fundamental question
that we also came to as a part of the
process modi
question of how is ethics incorporated
in even the outcome of our analysis
do we treat our work as if
not returning to receive services again
is a good thing or a bad thing
right coming back to receive services
again might mean
your transitional housing program that
was supposed to get you housing secure
has failed you but it also might mean
you had a bad experience with the system
and you're not willing to seek services
again if you need them
it also might mean that you've gotten
back on your feet through other methods
and you no longer need services
and so i think the quantity that we're
optimizing for
can't exist outside of the super nuanced
social context that we exist in
and figuring out how we wanna
understand and evaluate the outcomes of
our processes
in like requires an ethical
understanding of
all of the pieces of that puzzle
totally that reminds me um so there's a
piece on the checklist that speaks about
metric selection
and right as data scientists which i
think a number of us are
right we're used to training machine
learning models of course we have a
metric
so we can evaluate it and so there's
technical thoughts around like well
let's not use accuracy because we have
really unbalanced classes so we use f1
score right but there's really important
pieces to thinking through like what
what does this metric what is it
actually optimizing for and so like what
you were saying right when someone
doesn't return
for services that could be a good thing
that could be a very bad thing
and so like this this happened um there
is an article about this with youtube
where they were using they were trying
to
basically train a model to have better
autocomplete results for searching
and so the hypothesis is that they were
using
this metric around if people clicked on
what was presented to them
right of like you clicked on this
therefore this was like useful to you
this might have been what you were
looking for
but there are various reasons why people
click on things and that can be because
they're very bombastic
or outrageous or vile and so they had
this issue where the algorithm kept
surfacing videos with pedophilia
because when those were surfaced to
people people click on them out of you
know curiosity or what have you
uh and so it's this like tricky thing
around okay this metric is a good proxy
for what i care about
but it's also a proxy for things that i
really don't want to be surfacing
uh and so how do i navigate that do i
bring in additional metrics
do i have other ways of screening out
that content but right really thinking
through what does that look like in
practice
finally that toolkit sounds so amazing
and
i think i'm going to start using it
myself like that was
really awesome and i'm so excited about
it and i'm sure a lot of people here
will use it as well
um i would like i would like to talk a
little bit about the model selection
process
i think both of you talked about a lot
of ways
where you can even in like a traditional
model building you can so easily
introduce bias
right and when you have similar models
you can often kind of just
go back and trace to your input data to
see
where it's going through the model and
find a way to figure
figure out where the device is coming
from and try to fix it um i've been
working with
a lot of text data for the past couple
years and
um it's a space where deep learning
algorithms really tend to excel and i
think there is so much of a push towards
sexy data science and even like this is
what your employers want to see
it's what your customers want to see
right they want to see neural networks
and a really key problem if the field
is it's the bat it's the black box
problem right you
it's the challenge of just making sense
of how your algorithm is making
decisions
and in that case you can't really go
back to your input data and see what
your strongest features where you
have a really hard time figuring out if
your model is biased how it's biased
how do you create a ml system that
doesn't really discriminate
right um and there has been a lot of
recent work done in the field where
you're doing like post-hoc analysis
to make the models more explainable
there's like attention mechanisms and
um a whole bunch of different things um
but i do think some of those things
could also
be problematic in the sense where you're
explaining the model after it's already
making its predictions
which might not always be reliable they
can often be misleading
and i think those are a lot of things
that people need to think about when
weighing the options of
do i want a 99 accuracy score versus
like
a 92 accuracy score right um like how do
you
allow computer to make a decision that
you can't necessarily explain as a human
like what are the ethical considerations
of that
that reminds me of another example that
comes
that speaks exactly to explainability um
let me just say that part of the reason
why i have a lot of stories about things
times where things have gone wrong is
that as part of the documentation for
dion we created a page that basically
has
concrete examples of times where things
have gone wrong linked to each item on
the checklist and so that's a nice way
um so a lot of the things that i'm
talking about there are links to those
articles
um or research papers and so that's on
the
deon.drivendata.org link that i sent um
but the the story that i wanted to tell
here about that explainability
interpretability trade-off is
uh was exactly that it was in um
healthcare which is
of course an industry where we care
quite a bit uh why a model has made a
decision because it
can be a matter of life and death and so
um
some research awards were training this
model that was trying to predict
for patients who had um pneumonia
basically how
likely they were basically how likely
their what their risk of dying was
and so this was to prioritize care so
they could say this person is really
high risk so we're going to put them in
the icu
this person has a low risk so we can
send them home
and so when the researchers were looking
at the model they had they found this
really
odd finding they trained a neural
network and the model basically said
if this patient has asthma and has
pneumonia they're low risk
which is not true and then researchers
because they were medical professionals
as well
knew this and they said that doesn't
make any sense because when you have an
asthmatic patient
with pneumonia you send them right to
the icu because they're very very high
risk
and so what had happened in this model
right is that it had picked up basically
on the success
of the intensive care unit right and so
patients who had asthma who got admitted
to the icu
got really good care and survived and so
it was actually it wasn't until the
researchers ran this logistic regression
model to understand what's happening
here why did our
why is our model making this totally
wrong uh conclusion that they were able
to explain that
and so it just speaks to like there are
certain cases when we really care about
explainability and not just predictive
power
and i think healthcare is an industry
where this just comes up all the time
yeah i think that example too is really
relevant when we're
considering how many decisions we're
having to make on a on a massive scale
right now in the middle of a pandemic
and i just want to it's interesting too
because there's um
out of canada the i think it's called
read
research ethics data ethics there's been
a series of talks
that talk about different ways that race
gets inadvertently encoded into
medical diagnostics and so that happens
with kidney functions which is
important in covet and with lung
functions where particularly
black people are negatively impacted by
this
because they get a different output and
that kind of race-based biology
is of course not accurate and not right
and so in multiple ways
all of y'all brought up something that i
think is really interesting which is
what is measured is managed um
which i think is an old adage and also
um
oh goodness the data justice center in
the uk allison
wrote a whole series of pieces kind of
talking about this which i'll put in the
chat because i think they're really
interesting
um i think one thing that i'm curious
about
and i think others are too we've talked
about different
metrics right accuracy um
you know what what gender somebody is
how many
what's the number of something and i
think i'm curious about that in two ways
how to
if there's possibilities to choose a
better metric sometimes how do you
assess that
and then also what happens when you're
dealing particularly with a client that
wants certain things
measured whether that's a
you know kind of community client who
probably has the best intentions
or maybe a more corporate client or
partner
that will also say they maybe have the
best intentions but might not accept
that
as as much i'm curious if you have any
comments on that
like how to balance that kind of
choosing the right measurement with
choosing the
measurement that's wanted
yeah i mean i think part of it is is a
communication thing where
it's taking the time as a technical
person to understand
what are the pros and cons of different
metrics right what are
the trade-offs inherent in the different
metrics and because that arms you
with a way to then talk about that with
the client or the partner whoever that
is
to help service that so that this can be
like a joint decision because if they
have the best of intentions and you
present them with information that says
hey this is why this could be
problematic then that allows you to
actually have that conversation versus
just
like taking that on high and being like
we just have to do this and hope that it
works out
right but that requires that like due
diligence to be able to like investigate
and to like think about in this data
based on the way that this model is
structured what am i actually measuring
and is this actually getting what i want
right and i think that that's just
part of a role as a data scientist as
well
is is not just thinking about like um
like can i write code to do this but
like is this code actually doing the
thing that i wanted to be doing
right is this actually measuring what we
care about uh and if not then like what
are the modifications that we need to
make
yeah i want to pick up on what you just
said emily and like
think about it even in terms of the role
of the data scientist beyond
like actually writing code i think
getting to that question of what do you
actually want and what are the
incentives
that are structured around the decision
that someone's trying to make with the
data and with analysis
because i think something that i run
into a lot especially in the nonprofit
space
is a lot of folks want the best numbers
possible for donor reasons
because they're worried about
fundraising because they're trying to
tell a specific story
and i think when you can understand the
incentives that are
structuring a decision-making process in
that way then you can better understand
how to help data
how to help those decision makers use
data in a way that is both
accurate to the community that the data
describes but is also
useful in ways that help them meet their
needs
yeah i might open it up to a couple of
questions just to break it up before we
kind of
you know keep going um i know we have a
couple questions in
chat would anybody uh
let's see it's always um
would anybody have a question they'd
want to ask out loud or that could even
be one of your questions in chat
as well um this is bankster
how people can hear me so just what
charlotte mentioned about knowing the
incentive models for people who are
requesting the
results from the analysis of the data
can help figure out
what needs to be done with the data or
do it better but that also
inadvertently introduces bias into what
you may turn out
for the end users
so it seems like a double-edged sword
something that would actually swing
against you in terms of ethics you may
be doing the wrong thing
just to kind of uh provide a result that
is
supporting the incentive as opposed to
being truthful about if the incentive is
right or wrong
i can't answer that so i think i i
totally hear where you're coming from
and i think
to to articulate myself a little better
there
i think often you have a decision
maker who's pushing to use a specific
metric because they're
trying to understand a decision point
and figure out also how to meet their
needs programmatically
and there it's not so much about helping
fudge the numbers to help that decision
maker get away with whatever they want
but about actually meeting their needs
in a different way so it might be
that a non-profit wants to use a
volunteer hours metric that isn't
particularly descriptive
to really be able to tell the story of
what they're doing as an organization
but that doesn't make sense for the
context in the way that they're using
the numbers
but you might help them develop a
process to tell the stories of
volunteers who are coming to their
organization to give time
and their dedication to that work in a
way that isn't misleading
in the analysis process and isn't a
misuse of data and statistics
and like doesn't misrepresent anything
fundamentally so it's more about
separating that desire to push a metric
that maybe isn't the best
descriptor for a situation and like
helping move
whatever is kind of corrupting the
influence of that analysis
into a more productive space where
you're not misinterpreting anything but
you can still help the decision maker
get what they need in order to make the
decision they need to make
awesome i can take the the question
about um
how can we find disparities in existing
or proposed models before they cause
problems
um so in the same way that as
data scientists when we train models uh
and we look at how well they're doing
based on a set of metrics this is
exactly the time we want to be
investigating the predictions of our
model and and understanding them right
so there are things that we can do
that are you know after we've trained uh
our you know model or prototyped it but
are far before we go
deploying it where we can check for
fairness across groups and we can say do
we have
you know similar error rates um or are
we really just predicting well
on you know white americans and not
black americans right in this model for
example and like
that's the time when we want to not just
take the high level like oh it's got 90
accuracy but do that like investigative
piece to say hey what's happening here
why are predictions getting made what
are the variables that it's using
are those variables could they be
proxies for other things and so with
this
i don't want to make it sound like this
is an ex-ante thing that at the start of
the project you like
decide this is the set of things that
we're going to do this is very much
as you're going through that data
science workflow as you're doing
analysis as you're getting into the data
right you're doing that exploratory data
analysis and seeing hey we are really
imbalanced classes
that could bias our model right so when
i get to modeling i need to make sure
that i'm thinking about that and
under sampling or over sampling or
there's a whole set of things that you
can do there
uh same thing after your model's trained
that sort of diagnostic work and so this
is like
just part and parcel of the process and
this is not and it does a one-off thing
but it's really just kind of as you're
as you're going through it
um and then even when you get into like
model deployment
so that side of the checklist talks
about things like redress and like
roll back and so what happens if after
we've deployed our model we find out
that it is causing harm and we did our
best right to
check for these things but unforeseen
things happen we want to think before we
deploy do we have mechanisms that allow
us to
to to you know roll back the model to
stop it if it's causing harm to address
harm that's been caused
so those are the sorts of things that we
can still think about before the model's
been
deployed that set us up better um to
address
uh if there's harm caused later on
i think what what both of y'all
highlight and what the questions also
highlight
is that because this is a multi-step
process right so the toolkit went over
the entire
data life cycle or parts of it that
different decisions are made and
it seems to be that there needs to be
almost a consistent
documentation or at least a an effort to
document
at all the processes so that people can
go back
and see what happens or that people that
are affected by
by the the data or the modeling
decisions can see
how they've been affected and comment or
protest on that
i think that kind of brings me to
something else we we have been
discussing
um we've talked a little bit about
explainable ai and some of the
limitations for that a little bit uh i
think i loved what you said numa
a post talk analysis um that kind of
explains it but maybe doesn't fix it
right and i think one of the things that
i would like to ask next is
maybe a different way to look at
explainability or something
that should happen before is this
concept of accessibility to the data or
accessibility to the decision making
and i'm wondering what that even means
and something like open data
or kind of open source or even what this
group might be doing with community
partners
what does accessibility mean if you
actually need access to
things like github and coding and
additional knowledge particularly when
we're in the context of trying to serve
different groups that may not have the
the
technical know-how um you know i i did
not come from a
coding background um and so sometimes
had asked for extra questions throughout
the process when i got involved in
projects so
uh any any thoughts on on that um i know
i know numa did a really nice critique
of explainability and i'm curious if you
have any comments on
more on that or like the difference yeah
i think there's a lot of technical
gatekeeping
within the field and i think that with
an open data data sets don't necessarily
speak for themselves
so i think to understand or make sense
of the data you definitely need
very thorough documentation which
usually
isn't there and i think not having the
context behind the data
or truly understanding does end up
leading to
um a lot of the issues that we are
talking about
um i think that with an open source um
we definitely need to have more of a
responsibility
to making sure that our code is you know
our data is more accessible
um our code is at least in a way
where you can kind of explain what it is
doing
to a person who isn't very technical so
like
maybe they aren't going into the repo
and just um you know pip installing it
and running the code
but do they do they know what is going
to happen for someone who does do it
like can we be transparent about that
like what are the limitations of the
code
what are possible like biases or
anything we can introduce if let's say
you don't use the data set that they're
using or i think little things like that
um maybe big things like that
so yeah a lot of technical gatekeeping
that we should probably be mindful of
yeah i think even just things like
reproducibility right is huge
do we have we've written code in a way
that allows us to find an
error if there's an error right do we
have ways that make it easier
for other people to to read the code and
like that i totally agree with you
there's a ton
of gatekeeping and that requires
language
like you know code familiarity
programming language familiarity
but i think even just within the
technical world
uh we can do a better job at making
things more transparent right more
auditable essentially
oh if you're open for question a general
question to
uh data science folks on
in the panel uh maybe the panelists and
even other
other participants how often does your
team or other data science teams that
you can encounter
provide a list of threats to validity or
substitute an appropriate objective
instead of validity over there or not
uh along with the models that you toss
up for production
uh this is typical in uh software
engineering empirical
uh empirical software engineering papers
to state here's a set of textuality
based on the experiments that we've
conducted and the observations that we
provide
how prevalent is this practice in the
data science community
[Music]
so i think um
yeah so i you know what i might do is i
think that's a really broad question
i think we might have also kind of a
document at the end
and that's a question that almost
anybody here could answer about like
self-examining
what's what's kind of going on why don't
we have kind of a parking lot
document too so that at the end when we
break up the great breakout rooms we can
talk about more specific things
um that maybe affect somebody's
particular data
data project how does that sound to
y'all
um the other thing i was gonna say that
i sometimes follow
um does everybody here do like sci-fi
maybe not so corey doctorow does anybody
read his books he does this really
really interesting thing with um with
panels uh
where he tries to kind of uh always
try to switch around a little bit
whether it's a woman asking
the question or a man asking the
question and i might play with that a
little bit
um and that the next person that gets to
ask a question out loud
um is a woman or a person who identifies
as a woman or non-binary
it's obviously not perfect because we do
live in a non-binary world
um how does that sound to everybody kind
of thumbs up
okay cool but thank you for your
question it's always fun to have
participation and interest in this
um yeah i i think too
so talking a little bit more about kind
of accessibility and this gatekeeping
um i think one thing that's also
interesting too is that we're talking
about the gatekeeping in terms of
accessibility to being able to have
insight into the decisions and some of
these decisions have incredible
um power in determining the outcome of a
person's life
so i guess a popular book on that was
weapons of math
destruction but more recently and i
think this is kind of important to
consider
during an economic crisis two
is that increasingly now we're embedding
algorithms
in different ways that people make
hiring decisions so before it actually
reaches a person
then we we basically have kind of a
machine going through
and we know that biases can be
introduced through a
word and you know mispaired word
embeddings that are based on kind of an
old society rather than a society you
want to create
i am very curious about
even beyond this technical gatekeeping
what are the ways that kind of
social gatekeeping of
older world kind of mentalities getting
coded into the algorithms
what is are there any kind of ways to
correct that or
start to address that either technically
or through kind of conversations
are there you know what's the
explainability of social gatekeeping in
some way so that it can be
fixed
i can start out here uh i'll drop a link
in the chat to one of my favorite
articles on this topic
about specifically hiring algorithms um
and one of the funny examples that shows
up in it
is a company pitching a employee resume
screening algorithm
where once they kind of did a deep dive
into the features
the two most predictive uh features for
job performance were if your name was
jared and if you played high school
lacrosse and so while those things were
incredibly predictive in the dataset
they used
not something we necessarily want to be
socially reproducing
uh and it also talks about amazon having
a similar problem in trying to build a
resume screening tool for almost a
decade
and no matter what they did the
algorithm would systematically
rank female applicants lower and if the
word women
appeared like in women's sports or i
went to a women's college
it would it would count against that
applicant um and so i think
often our uh understandings of bias in
the way that we use data
are limited to whether the data is more
biased than the social system which is
creating the data
and i think often because we stop there
we miss a whole
huge chunk of the ways that we are
replicating and socially encoding
a lot of these systems i saw someone
drop the link in the chat to like a
futuristic predictive policing system
this is another way right that we
take the past and we push it on to the
future by encoding
the biases of the past into our data
because we can only
train on historical data so especially
with predictive policing
if you send more cops to a neighborhood
there are going to be more arrests in
that neighborhood which
precipitates this cycle and so i think
as data scientists we have to push
ourselves to think beyond
minimizing bias that steps above the
social biases that we didn't see and
think kind of deeply about the questions
that
we all kind of struggle with being in
society like what do we want these
systems to look like
and i think that's i think it's a big
question we all have to answer a lot
yeah i would just like to echo that and
say that your algorithm is only as good
as the data you put in it
it's really just going to tell you what
your data is
yeah that's yeah i'd want a third both
of those it's
it's so like the amazon example is so
interesting because
they did the like investigative thing
into saying hey we know that this is
biased against women so like let's try
to fix it and let's remove gender from
our model and like
what is it predicting and yeah it's like
picking up on like you know women's
sports but it's also picking up on
language
right language that women are more
likely to use than men
and so this gets exactly to like what
charlotte was saying about these and
numa as well these like social
structures
where we don't want to use the algorithm
that's systematically biased against
women
but we also know that our current hiring
process sees
that all of us hold lots of implicit
biases and
and also judge people based on language
and a whole host of factors and physical
appearance and
like right all of these things and so
it's uh
it's a really tricky problem and it's
often set up as like oh this is more
biased than is this more or less biased
than the humans since that's why i
really loved what you said in charlotte
about like it's not just this like
comparison of like
which one's worse but like what's the
what do we want this little to look like
um i really like them yeah i loved i
love the uh phrase push
the the past into the future too because
i think that's
that's really important um i will say
one comment on that amazon algorithm
that was
discriminated against woman uh
applicants
it took them two years to fix it and i
think it was because of a
kind of pr thing so they were aware that
there was a problem and just
it wasn't cost effective i think to
to fix it in some ways which is very
intriguing and makes you
kind of think about the different um
incentives
um with that too i think you know
talking a little bit more about
hiring algorithms because that affects
all of us so much
um some of the newer hiring algorithms
actually rely on kind of identifying
different facial expressions and facial
features
we know that facial surveillance
does a worse job identifying um
black faces and even though
uh you know there's been this moratorium
on facial surveillance technologies i
think by ibm and amazon or at least the
research and deployment of them for at
least a year
until there's better uh kind of
regulations around that
companies such as higher view which
maybe
aren't as broadcast as they as the big
you know
five tech companies are still deploying
this technology
i'm curious if y'all have any comments
on kind of the different ways that
racial bias
and gender bias but i think an
acknowledgement of the black lives
matter
movement i'd really like to focus on the
racial bias and how that gets introduced
and different ways to kind of address
that both
not so much technically but then also
through kind of power building and
consensus outside of the tech community
so just from a technical perspective and
then i i might put it over to
charlotte um to talk about like the
broader systems
uh i i i feel like a lot of things we
talk about
in dion and like in the checklist are
things where like data scientists have a
particular
responsibility but they're not the only
people that need to care about data
ethics
and so i feel like this example of
facial recognition gets to that broader
piece where it's not just like how do
you do this ethically
right and so there are things we can do
there in terms of like the data sets
that it's trained on
right part of the reason why we're so
bad at identifying black faces is
because we don't have
like our data sets are like
predominantly white faces right and so
there are pieces
there but then there's this much broader
piece around like how is this technology
being used
what is the accountability structures
there is this ethical to create given
that there are so many
potential uses and abuses of the model
uh and so it's it's it's not
just this like how could like i don't
want to just frame it isn't like how can
we do this unethical thing ethically
right
yeah i think it's one of the limitations
that you have when
you're working as an individual person
as opposed to a collective body
because as an individual data scientist
there's only so much that you can do
with what you have as opposed to working
as a collective body where you can
actually work through the implications
of the model and how you would actually
go about addressing it
yeah i could happen as well like emily
to build on your point not even
just are there not enough black faces in
the data sets we're training people on
but there is racial bias fundamentally
encoded into the process of photography
because photography is normalized based
on white skin colors
and so i think to step into the like
kind of bigger scope of the social level
of these things
when a lot of the questions about fish
recognition especially used by the
police
were kind of coming up in data science
in data science spaces
a lot of folks were talking about how
these facial recognition algorithms were
less predictive for black faces
and what the implications of that would
be would be in a crime space
and there were a lot of data scientists
who care a lot about racial justice who
are
speculating that this actually might be
a positive thing right like making
people less visible to the surveillance
state
as a positive thing because they were
less likely to be recognized
and there were a lot of jokes about like
being less likely to be killed by robots
like in the facial recognition future um
and i think
what we've actually seen is because
they're systematically worse at
recognizing black faces
they're starting to be more and more
cases where someone is misidentified as
a suspect
because the recognition algorithms work
less for black faces
and then that shows up as evidence
against them if there's a 98
match with your face and a blurry other
face of someone of your race
but it's not you that's evidence against
you even if you're demonstrably innocent
um and so i think even thinking about
the ways the biases play out in the
social context in which they exist
i think that's where even biases that
seem like they might
favor a group in making them less
visible to like
harmful forces can eventually be
weaponized against them
i think that part is really interesting
to the whole
i think when we're talking about kind of
eliminating bias we're trying to um
sometimes we don't take into account
that the harm has been perpetuated by
a system long before we're actually
creating an algorithm
so in this case that uh black people can
be hurt by recognition and can be
hurt by lack of recognition it feels
kind of screw to see do screws you don't
and that a lot of the kind of technical
fixes
often happen a little bit too late um
i'm curious to what that means
for actually kind of doing
this the context of data work and if
y'all can comment
a little bit on how to include people in
like kind of the
the pre-data aspect of doing
data and tech types of things in a more
ethical way if that ethics also has to
include
the participation and power
of people and how to do that or if
you've seen anybody do it well
and the answer might be is that people
don't do it wow and that's that's part
of the problem you know like i know
um in silicon valley less than two
percent of engineers are black
you know i don't know what the
percentages of indigenous or latinx
you know but what does that mean for the
entire yeah i'm leading the question out
with the answers i want but i'll let you
all
[Music]
i can hop on first uh i think this goes
to the missing perspectives item on the
dion checklist
which is like who's in the room and
you're having these conversations um
emily i think to the example you brought
up earlier right
they only figured that out because they
were doctors right like they only
knew something was wrong in that process
because they were doctors
and this is something i think about a
lot as someone who is often
looking at data that does not involve me
as someone who's directly impacted and i
think the most complicated example of
this in my work is
um doing work looking at racial
disparity in removals for black children
in foster care
right that's a circumstance that we
also cannot directly involve
participants
in that system in that analysis because
of confidentiality reasons because
they're children because they're deeply
traumatized frequently
and i think this question is a lot
easier to answer
the more accessible your the folks in
your data are
and the more you can get community
stakeholders around the table this looks
different for every context whether it's
a business whether you're
looking at your consumers whether you're
looking at your constituency
um in different in different kinds of
places but i think
who is at the table shapes what you know
about
how processes work so a lot of times
what we see in community-based data work
is when you actually involve people with
lived experience they're able to point
point out systematic holes in systems or
in processes that like you never would
have noticed
in data right you might be offering an
incentive system for someone to
participate in a program
but it doesn't work if they don't have
access to the bus because it doesn't run
at that time so unless you can
understand the components
of the system that exists outside of the
data and what you can measure
you often can't get to the heart of the
questions you're actually trying to
measure or know what's useful to measure
to go back to the
kind of metric selection question
yeah absolutely and there was a comment
earlier in the chat that
um was asking whether this is like
outside the responsibility of data
scientists to think about discrimination
um and i feel strongly that this is part
of the data scientist responsibility and
it doesn't require
like this entirely separate education we
shouldn't think about it as being
entirely separate right we have the
variables in our data set to understand
how they're related
to each other right and so taking that
discrimination
lens uh is is not only part and parcel
of like exploring the data
but it's also just i think that there's
an inherent responsibility
of data scientists to understand their
data and so sometimes that means going
to stakeholders and saying
hey like we're trying to understand this
variable like we do this all the time at
driven data because we work
in a ton of different industries we do
stuff in financial inclusion we do stuff
in healthcare we do stuff in education
we work in like conservation research
and like identifying
animals and camera trap videos i mean
like super disparate things
and so like we can't be experts in all
of those fields and so part of our
process
is spending time with the client and
going through the data and sharing our
understanding right we've explored the
data this is what we think these things
mean
is this correct right are we like we're
seeing this finding does this make sense
to you
and that those are the conversations
that let you start to understand like
oh this data is you know this part of
the data is fundamentally different or
came from a different process
um or the more about that that
additional context right
uh we've also done work with ido.org
and they're a design research firm they
do really fantastic qualitative research
and so so in some of our work where
we've looked at like use of digital
financial services and mobile money
um in places like tanzania we've done
really in-depth
work with them where they're doing
on-the-ground research and understanding
how are women engaging with mobile money
right like what are some of the barriers
what are some of the bottlenecks and
then that's paired with us doing
quantitative analysis
and so that's a more extreme example of
like pulling in those
the understanding of like what's
happening on the ground and then what's
happening
in the data and so this isn't to say
like you should always have a team of
qualitative researchers like
giving you context but just that like
reflecting back
this is our understanding of the data
that we're documenting it we're having a
conversation or
and at the very minimum being aware of
who's not in the room
right who haven't we talked to that we
wish we could have
uh rape just doing that reflection of
like who's on our
team right like there's there's a this
case gets talked about a lot with with
apple where they
you know designed this healthcare app so
you could track all these like
super crazy things uh about your health
and and you couldn't track your period
right and this is like one of the things
that like a lot of women want to do
right and like the hypothesis is that
that team was mostly male developers and
so
like having that conversation around
like who's on our team and then even
like for people that aren't
data scientists who are like setting
teams right thinking through
like how are we building teams on an
organizational level right this is like
that next level up of like how do we set
teams up
for success um and like understand what
are what are the blind spots how do we
fill those in
you know the very minimum just being
aware of what some of those are
yeah that's all that yeah i think that's
all really really interesting and we
want big and theoretical which is where
i
tend to like to sit um i think
one we've kind of hit another around 20
minute mark so just to kind of give you
um i want to take another question from
the crowd and
uh you know confirming what i said
earlier incorporating dr burrows kind of
thing
i really love it either in the if it's
from the chat or if anybody who
identifies as a woman or non-binary
would like to ask a question um and
probably in about 10 minutes or so me
and all the other panelists are going to
take a five minute just turn off our
screens uh
anybody else can take a break too and
then come back and kind of come for the
last
round so just uh to give you kind of a
direction of
of the next uh 20 minutes or so
there's some good questions in the chat
let's see does anybody
who wrote a question in the chat or let
me would like to ask it out loud if not
i can read one
let's see
some of the some of the questions are
longer
well so i think sorry it's actually hard
to like read through the questions in
the chat while moderating a little bit
so i apologize for that
um i think there's been some comments uh
kind of generally a couple times oh it's
in the dock
um yeah
oh are all the questions in the doc too
then not in the chat
i got got blind in the headlights for a
minute nope
no problem so my question that i asked
was about um if you collect data you
know initially for
one purpose what are the ethical
considerations about using it
afterwards for a secondary purpose you
know how do you validate
that the context is appropriate to use
it for a different purpose
yeah i think this is a super important
question worth asking i don't think i
have a
um i think that that's very context
dependent right and so i think part of
it is understanding
what was the like informed consent
portion in the original data collection
and does this permit the secondary use
of it
right is it open data that has been you
know licensed for various purposes
right like sometimes there's that
additional information i think like
reaching out to organizations who
collected the data um to
basically understand if that use is
allowed
is a great way to to tackle that in
terms of like
the validity of the data i think and
like the accuracy in terms of being able
to use it for another purpose
i think that's where it just becomes
really important to understand like
what's in that data
and to the extent that you can
understand the data collection process
for it
um so for certain like household survey
data sets that i work with
that have been collected and are like
publicly available i often look at the
like
technical report that goes along with it
to understand their sampling design
to say okay this is what it was sampled
to do i can use it for nationally
representative
i can use it for like country wide
statistics but i can't
you know it's not been sampled to have
validity at like a district level
right and so i think part of it is like
understanding what's
in that data what it was designed for
and so then you as a data scientist i
think have to make
some of that call right of like
is is this statistically valid right
what am i missing right
under like reading the code book if it's
a survey data that's a great way to
understand like what wasn't
asked um but yeah digging into that for
sure
i know this is a huge issue and kind of
the quantified self and what some of the
the larger companies uh do so like
google bought fitbit
and uh i use fitbit so it meant
that i let fitbit use my data but now
google
has access to it and i think um that's
where the regulatory framework too
has just not caught up in some ways
um but that it becomes really
problematic because what happens if an
insurance company buys google
yeah and i think it's just tricky also
just as like a civilian
like not like even like taking off my
data scientist hat
and being like who has access to my data
and like did i consent to that and like
there were a lot of terms and conditions
and like what is like what do those
actually mean like i think it's really
hard
just as like citizens to like understand
who actually has access to our data and
like how to control that even being like
a technically savvy person
i think that we have a long ways to go
in in society
um and maybe new manchester united can
talk more about this but just like of
how
here's your thoughts like how do we like
what could that look like or like how do
we even get to a point where we feel
like we actually have control over
our data or do we just have we just kind
of given that up given the age that we
live in
you know
i can hop in and listen to what you want
to happen
um yeah sure um yeah i think that's
i think it's a difficult problem right i
think that we
i think in some ways that i think in
some ways that we
almost consent to our data being used
because we want better things
um i think we do that maybe on a daily
basis with things like apple watch with
our iphones we do it with um
like just better recommendations on
netflix or hulu or whatever we're doing
i think in some ways we almost consent
to our data being used so we get better
things
um but what are the ethical implications
of that
um yeah i don't necessarily have a good
answer to this except that
it's a tricky problem and i think that
we need to
figure out a good balance between
how much data privacy we need and
um how much
how many good things we need
emily i mean yeah i was actually going
to chime in just to say
that i agree it's a difficult problem
and i don't think there's going to be an
easy solution and
sometimes the ethical response is
even in your tactics so if you were to
go look at for example
twitter's privacy policy they've
explicitly
written it in a way that's not lawyer to
lawyer
but to you as a citizen to understand
how and why we're using your data so
yes there's potential easy pass through
right the risk reward or the benefit
cost analysis for
sharing my data but i think there's some
organizations
of scale that are trying to be very
pro you know informational or very
transparent about how and why they're
using it and
again in ways that are not just small
fine prints and lawyer to lawyer
but rather you know us to you to make
sure that you understand the agreement
we're entering into
getting back to emily's point about
consent
emily i think your point about your
question like should we just give up
right like
we're giving away so much data
constantly and especially we might be
willing to give away data in specific
context
the fact that that data is packaged and
resold and in conjunction with other
data that other companies have on us
is like incredibly identifying and very
detailed about our lives
and this is something i think about a
lot and and
taking also taking off my data
scientists have i think
often the strategies that we employ in
the digital world are the same
strategies that we might employ
in the physical world right if there's
surveillance around you
what are the solutions like what are the
things you can do to like minimize the
effect of the surveillance audio
but in the digital world we often limit
ourselves to those like physical world
creativity
so something i think a lot of a lot
about is uh
in the digital world we have
possibilities that we don't have in the
physical world so one thing you could do
in the digital world
is send out digital clones of yourself
to go do a bunch of arbitrary things on
the internet
and pollute the data source as
frustrating as that might be to us
thinking about
using that data in any way there are
ways for kind of citizens to fight back
against these abuses of power
if i can set up a bot on my computer to
google
random words related to construction in
estonian i'm going to get
really really different google search
results and google ads which is going to
break me a little bit out of my
algorithmic bubble
and so i think we need to broaden our
understanding of how we fight back
against these abuses of power
into digital specific ways like i can't
send out people who look exactly like me
to do inconspicuous things all over
washington dc
but in digital spaces i can do that and
i think we haven't been able to
collectivize that power yet but i think
there are ways to kind of come together
and like fight for our
privacy and fight for our like
collective rights and responsibilities
um in ways that are creative if not a
little bit
uh disruptive
i love that about kind of digital
cloning and the uh
kind of the speculative fiction ways of
of fighting back and i think there's
going to be like an incredible
um wonderful ways to do that um
as we kind of move forward um
yeah so i want to give the panelists i
think this is a good time to maybe just
give a
five-minute break and give anybody else
here a five-minute break um just because
we've been
kind of talking for over an hour or so
and then we'll come back
um and talk a little bit more we thought
we'd kind of finish the night looking a
little bit at disinformation
so that's just a little teaser just
because that's very much on the minds
and actually has some really interesting
um issues in terms of everything from
labeling to
like the narratives that are going to
affect us in a month
when there's an election i hope that
everybody's registered to vote
one time and also a little homework
tomorrow is to call five friends and
make sure they're registered to vote and
have a plan
because we live in a democracy so
still all right uh i'm gonna turn off my
screen for five minutes
uh so that means that like 7
30 uh eight uh according to my watch
then i'll open it up again
and and give everybody a chance to
either take a break or
the non-panelists can chat among
themselves too
okay
for folks that are still around um i
think we only have another minute before
everyone else comes back but oh okay i
think
i've missed and people are coming back
i was originally going to say we could
have some chatting
in the meantime but it looks like we're
ready to to get back into things
there are a couple good questions um in
the chat
in text based during the the
intermission uh
i just tried to google 10 things to try
to remember what it is but um
i work at x and our user experience team
runs surveys and a lot of things where
ethics are often involved
and there was some questions around what
kind of ethics organizations are in the
boston area
or a potential for like a hippocratic
host for a data scientist
i know in the academic space whenever
there's any sort of
clinical trial or research experiment
there's often a
review board that has a name that i'm
sure somebody here knows the name of
at like an academic institution
i see i got the last two words part of
it internal review which um
oftentimes will have like a checklist so
even though uh i'm an mit employee
but i don't work with mit directly
whenever we do
any sort of user experience surveys we
copy from their irb because we're not
bound by them but they provide a bunch
of resources that we then
read and it's sort of a deon-esque
checklist that we think about
and other people in the university do
actually are required to get approval by
the rb before they start collecting data
about people
so i don't know if that's boston centric
or something like that but mit's irb
does produce a lot of resources that are
available to the public
i assume other universities do as well
yeah that's that's really interesting
there there was an effort to create a
hippocratic oath for data scientists
um a few years ago funded by omidyar
um and i think it was
one of the things is that
i think one of the things that data
science needs before like a
data credit oath could be created is
that it has to be a profession with like
kind of licensing so that's why it works
so well
for physicians in particular is because
you have a medical board that can take
away your license after a particular due
process
and one of the amazing things about
attack
is also the limitation in this process
is that anybody can become a data
scientist
well anybody with access to internet
time
financial resources but you can
generally kind of jump in without
getting kind of a
license to do data scientists science
work so that would be my only comment
i was involved in the hippocratic oath
project so i was pretty familiar with
uh why it didn't work
i know we have a lot of questions in the
doc and what i'm hoping is at the end
um in about you know 15 or 20 minutes we
have a couple questions here people jump
in it's a little bit of a free-for-all
and then if people want to stay and chat
then we do it in the breakout rooms
where it's just a little bit easier to
to have a conversation
but i wanted to get to disinformation
because it's kind of close to my heart
as well and i think a really really
complex
topic that gets on to a lot of the
points that we've spoken about earlier
uh power agency bias um
even looking at where uh kind of
data science or tech is generally done
which is in north america
um in a lot of places and how that kind
of affects some of the ways that we even
look
and can ethically mandate different
things
um yeah and so
i don't know if any of y'all have seen
some of the news recently but sophie
sang
was a former facebook employee and she
released an internal move
memo that was reported on by craig
silverman
uh i don't know if everybody's read that
that's like a huge
i've seen it all over the news the past
couple days but that might not be
what everybody's seen and thank you
charlotte for
dropping it in there um but effectively
the big thing that jumped out to me
um was that she said that facebook was
able to prioritize
which narratives and where those
narratives were located
um to the detriment of not focusing on
other parts of the world
um and so for instance those they tended
to focus on disinformation that was
created by networks that were
affecting um the united states or europe
primarily and if there wasn't enough
time
they never got to parts of africa or
latin america
and so that was that was kind of
interesting to me and i kind of wanted
to bring
in two how do we determine
which things and anything we're talking
about
whether they're narratives uh whether
they're kind of
which aspects of ethics which ones get
noticed or regulated
or analyzed um i'm also really excited
to have numa on the panel because she's
been
looking at disinformation for a really
long time and some of that complexity
so i might open it up to you first
but i think the question is even broader
than this information in some ways
yeah so i think who has the power to
make the decision with what narratives
we get noticed
is it's a really really important one um
i think
that especially for i think at least for
companies that
kind of look at the problem from the
outside so not being a social media
platform
or you know a new source um i think a
lot of that
is unfortunately driven by
the people that fund us so the people
who are paying us to do the research
are probably interested in you know
if they're paying us in the us they
probably would want to know about what's
going on in the u.s therefore we don't
really look at
narratives that are happening in africa
or latin america or south america
um which which is a little concerning
because those places also do have issues
that we should be looking at they do
show up on our social media feeds all
the time
um how do we also figure out what
narratives to look at then i mean a lot
of these i think would give you
like we're really interested in looking
at coronavirus or we're really
interested in the 2020 elections
so what what narratives do you even look
at within
that broad topic right and
different places i've worked at have
done this differently but i think the
question is really how do we figure out
what is
more harmful is that something that we
can even do
like how do you figure out the risk and
impact right so
are you looking at things that are not
supported by facts are you looking at
promotion of distress and science
government
social institutions um promotion of
discrimination exclusion
are you looking at violent criminal acts
are you looking at harassment
dehumanizing
language what is more harmful how is
that a question that you can even how do
you
answer that it's not as simple i think
as a lot of other fields where
i don't know like you're looking at just
things like okay people dying
yes that's like the most harmful thing i
think this information is so much more
nuanced than that because it can
probably affect generations to come so
how do you
how do you figure that out
it's interesting because even you
describing the different types of harm
or the different types of narratives
helped make it more clear to me
how to kind of start to slot what those
different potentials for harm
are so i feel like there's kind of
a couple issues here there's also like
what do you what do you label those
narratives
and then going back to the very
beginning how do you measure
how do you manage what's measured like
how do you measure harm and this this is
an issue of course
and everything this is the kind of the
heart and soul of at least
medical ethics which often kind of grew
into other types of ethical
considerations now i agree i think
i think measuring harm or measuring risk
is something that i have
worked with a lot of people in the past
couple years to come up with the
framework that works
and it is just so nuanced and there's so
many other good considerations and
decisions to even think about
that it's not something that we've even
come close to solving right like it's
i talked to a lot of disinformation
researchers who
come up with their own different ways of
like this is what we think is more
harmful than this but then
i think that's very biased if it's kind
of based on that soul person right
they're like okay well
we think promotion of distress in
science is so much more harmful
than promotion of discrimination um
but why yeah
i guess i'll open it to the whole panel
but i think that
what you're bringing up also is a
trade-offs uh
in disinformation and choosing which
part to focus on
but then also in ethics at large do we
choose to focus on
privacy or do we choose to focus on uh
fairness and there
doesn't have to be shakeoffs with those
but often it feels like different
projects tend to
try to to kind of bring one more into
sharper relief than another
um and i'm curious if any of y'all kind
of think about like what are
some of the almost beyond a checklist
how do you with limited time and
resources try to focus
on on a couple different things that
have the most impact
and there might not be an answer to that
question either
um because i think it's really really
hard and sometimes we're determined
we our priorities are also determined by
kind of the project that we're put on
and the
company that we're working for um and so
i wonder to
um so let's go to something a little bit
you know kind of within that
when we take it to labeling nemo you
mentioned
that oftentimes it's a couple different
people that get to kind of label the
narrative
what's the next step like how do we
begin to fix that
yeah i think i think we need to maybe
just move back
and talk about can we even label this
information and if we do label this
information
who has the power to label it if we have
multiple people labeling it
do we have multiple um
is it is it a diverse group of people
labeling it right can we make sure we're
not introducing bias
in our label collection in our data
collection
um i think we need to
try to address that first before we
even have like a collection of label
data that we are putting into models
um i think that so the company i worked
at before this
we got around this problem by not
labeling data at all we were just like
we're just going to use all these
unsupervised techniques because
the labeling data introduces so much
bias we
don't really know if we can do this you
know in the way that we should be doing
it
um which which is great but then that
limits you so much because then it's
really hard for you to detect narratives
or disinformation
um when you're only using unsupervised
techniques
i'm sure there's ways to do it and we
definitely did it
in certain ways but it didn't always
work um and i mean sure like with
supervised techniques it doesn't always
work either but it does give you um
you do have more options and there's
more that you can do with it
if you label data i think it makes
things a lot easier for data scientists
in that way
but easy isn't always great either
so i think there's just like a lot of um
i think there's just a lot of things
um like pros and cons and just ethical
contributions that you have to make and
think about when you are going to go
label something as nuanced ask this
information
go to your early earlier question of
stepping beyond checklist now that i've
thought about i have an answer
uh i think one of the best things that
you can do besides
um using the kind of dion checklist to
evaluate your technical work
is to understand what happens to your
work when it moves beyond your desk in
the organization i think data science
teams and technical teams are often so
siloed i think to emily's earlier
description of her work right
this process of actually kind of coming
in contact with the end stakeholders of
your data
is not standard in the field and so i
think that's definitely something that
needs to change culturally
i think a good example in the disc
information space is
facebook made the platform accessible in
different languages before they had
moderators in those languages
so that was a technical decision that
was made without consultation kind of
with the broader
like facebook community to try to figure
out what are the implications of making
this technical decision
for the way other parts of our business
process operate i think that really
speaks to the silent nature of technical
work often
um which means that the ethical
considerations and
programmatic considerations are
disjointed
often and how they're implemented yeah
and i think that
right there's that like what happens
after
uh like i really agree with your point
about the problematic
piece of it being siloed i think there's
also that piece before like who's
working on what like that's what struck
me about
the facebook memo was this person saying
hey i had to make decisions because i
was so under resourced and those were
having
implications in terms of like electoral
outcomes in other countries
and there are so many people working on
spam but aren't working on this type of
disinformation and so like that's where
this whole idea of data ethics requires
that like organizational
commitment to it like at all levels of
like how are we you know
not just who's on our teams but like how
many resources are we are we dedicating
to this um to make sure that
right because if you if you understand
okay this area is getting so
under resourced then you start to
understand those downstream consequences
of it but it's
and and like i get that this gets to be
tricky when you
factor in profit and like what's the
right thing to do with the bottom line
um but i guess my point here is really
just that like those conversations have
to be happening
like at all levels of the company it's
it's not just technical teams it's like
you know c-suite execs too yeah i think
you have to think of the problem as a
collective body
like you can't just be thinking of it as
a single data scientist it just doesn't
work that way
i also think if we're calling a
particular
department within facebook under
resourced
it's a very much a very sharp criticism
against a very well resourced
company as well and i think that's
also a really interesting thing that we
should all consider
is that if we want to introduce ethics
to our companies
we got to say where is the money and the
time
and the personnel to actually implement
this in a way
like you know it's the heart of the
company or the money of the company
actually in this
yeah we can't just be dotting our t's
we're
dotting our eyes crossing our t's um and
saying like oh you know we did it like
that's
you know like even even just like in the
framing of dion right it's like how do
we have these discussions
right again like how do we how do we
think about this on our team it's it's
not like oh well i
you know i don't have gender and i don't
have this and like oh i have you know
at least five people working on this
issue like they're not these simple
things and so it's like that's why we as
like the tech sector have to come to
terms with this
um because it's it's not it's not simple
fixes and it really is this like
um like organizational discussion
and and like i agree with you that
there's
at some point like a value like putting
that value explicitly
right and saying like we are going to
like spend the time and the resources
to do this right and not just
to like do it easily i also like
that being said i don't want to make it
sound like to do things ethically you
have to spend
like you know 3x the amount of time and
3x amount of money i
i don't think that like just thinking
about my
like my own work and like what it's been
like to use this checklist in my own
processes
i don't feel like it's added a dramatic
amount of time and resourcing to
projects
and so i don't want us to set this up as
like oh companies aren't doing this
because
like it takes up too much work uh i
think that
there's like an intentionality that
comes from it of like right having this
be part of like what's expected and
what's in that routine and it gets
faster than more that you do it
um but it's it's not that we're like
writing a phd thesis on every model with
like
for all of the like discriminatory
effects that i could have right and we
can still make like really significant
ethical gains
um by like doing this consistently even
even if it's in seemingly like small
amounts
yeah that's really that's really
interesting i'll have to sit with that
for a little bit
um just because i sometimes worry i
think
i sometimes get concerned uh like
working within
this field that it maybe doesn't add too
much
time or resources to the particular
project or like it just takes a little
bit more
but that if the entire business model is
not
kind of um reconfigured in
in a way where we don't need these kind
of massive profits
through the exploitation of data
essentially
um then
i don't know i mean i don't want to
leave it on that note but i think i
think it's really really interesting
to think about like what is the
difference we can make within our
particular
system but then how do we expand from
there
and change bigger
i think we're reaching towards kind of
you know does anybody have any questions
um before we break out into a couple uh
breakout rooms
um i also just want to give a big hand
to the panelists i think
you know we and everybody here uh as
well but especially the panelists for
showing up
letting me ask random theoretical
questions
as they came to my mind even though i
had a few questions i'd sent to them
i'm just letting me kind of pick their
brains and learn a lot from them
i've written some of your phrases and
notes and taking that back to all
my like ethical work as well so so thank
you
all of you
and with that we'll open up to a couple
questions
um either that i prefer if people ask
them out loud because the chat kind of
goes
through me like a little bit quickly and
ben's hopefully created a document
that um when we break down into the
breakout rooms and kind of chat casually
for
the last part of the evening then then
we can kind of address
some of them too
ah cool thank you
this is this is an um i think this is
actually a really interesting question
for the group
so adam blackwell asked if there's
anybody's aware
of a guide for collecting demographics
or any type of kind of gender data from
events
and how to use that data to help to
create policies that maybe
address some of the issues of making a
community more inclusive
i don't know if a document exists but i
think
i'm curious if any of the panelists do
and if not would encourage either
boston data science or pi data boston to
maybe think about starting to
to crowdsource and collect and make that
document
thanks for throwing me in for this pack
on us
i'm just gonna say i don't know if i
document um but i think it would be
really awesome
if um boston actually gets together to
do it
i guess i have uh so i asked during this
event one of my
uh closer friends who's non-binary um
for some advice on this
because uh we did a practice for
physical events but
don't and that trend it is actually
quite useful for boston data science um
but it's
poor data and i'm cautious about how it
gets used because it could be used
improperly potentially the suggestion
that i have and i'll maybe put this here
in case people want to do it or
want to use it is in the beginning event
to suggest that people put their
preferred pronouns
if you like expand out i put him next to
my name
in zoom which you can do by like
clicking on the more and renaming
yourself
um and then it's voluntary information
if you don't want to volunteer
then you know it's self-reported data um
i don't know what that would look like
but i see a couple of other people doing
it so
i appreciate that
and maybe we'll try to mention that in
the beginning of an accident
yeah i think it's really helpful to
normalize that i know
you know for most of the um
first several years of my career that
was not a normal practice and i still
have to remind myself to
to add it in so
now i'm still thinking about your your
point about like this changing from
like changing the fundamental structure
versus like changing from within i'm
curious to get
like broader thoughts on like other
panelists but maybe other people too
like i i don't know like it's it's
tricky because it's like you want to do
something
right and you want to do but ultimately
you don't want to just reinforce
the status quo and the systems that are
like causing a bunch of these
inequities and like ethical issues and
so there's this balance between like
starting to like integrate this data
ethics into our everyday work and also
like
moving that upwards to be systemic
change
and i i just it's it's
tempting to say like oh we don't need to
do like bigger forms and if only
we just like are all more intentional
that's enough and i agree with you like
your pushback that's like that's that's
not uh i also think that starting with
like the biggest thing
uh can lead to inaction um
so i'm curious for other reflections or
thoughts on that
and so i previously worked at a company
where we
um created the council um and the idea
behind that was it was a bunch of us who
were really interested
in looking into the ethics of what we
were doing which was in the
disinformation space
um can be really important so like once
a week we would get together
talk about the work we were doing um the
customers that we had
um how we were collecting data
what um like water models were
outputting and especially given that we
weren't fully labeling any data so we
had a lot of unsupervised techniques
just
like grouping um data collection like
these
collections of data together and what
that really meant
um like did that even make sense so a
lot of these things that we're talking
about we would kind of talk through
in like this 10 15 person group and we
would try to take it
to our leadership and um walk them
through what we were thinking
if there was anything we were concerned
about if there was something that we
just didn't necessarily agree with
um and i want to say that it was
i wouldn't say it was super successful
but i do think it helped
i think at the very least it helped us
be a lot more conscious of the work that
we were doing
i think i was definitely
more mindful of data science work that i
was doing of the data that i was looking
at
of the data that i was giving our
clients of the narratives that we were
supporting like i think that
it at the very least helped all of us be
more
mindful of what we were doing so maybe
something like that in your own
companies
and i think too you might not change it
at that first company but getting the
practice
and um
when you move to the next company you
already have some fluency
um too and like kind of what what you
know you want to talk about and you come
in and gradually shift
um i think the practices um
of the next next company particularly as
the whole industry shifts
i i i do think that there can be
um paralysis in trying to tackle the
biggest problem
first but it's nice to always keep that
kind of in the in the viewfinder
[Music]
i'm kind of curious from maybe this is a
little bit of a pull
but um you know when we talk about
ethics and other stuff
is there anything i kind of like to
think so i am very worried about
how disinformation will affect my life
um particularly because i'm working in
public health right now
but i don't know if i have kind of a
daily like worry about how
an algorithm is not fair enough or
something like that in part because i am
you know part of the educated
privileged white uh class
in so many ways and i'm kind of curious
if people ever get worried about the
negative impacts of an algorithm and
you don't have to answer but maybe it's
just kind of a question to pose to
yourself
um and where that places us in terms of
kind of
the power to be able to talk about it
and change it
but maybe not the vulnerability of
having to be worried
that's a really great point on privilege
right of like
are you do you are you like unavoidably
worried
about the impact of an algorithm
and i'm terrified of facebook's
algorithm on a daily basis
you know but
i think we all should be worried about
facebook's algorithm on a daily basis
yeah well i think your part about
privilege is like
super important to consider so just
taking a quick example
from um work i've done the homelessness
space i
did a lot of work assessing the validity
of a scale called the vulnerability
index service prioritization decision
assistance tool
with a very terrible acronym vi sped
but essentially what the tool is used
for is is to determine whether
um folks who are seeking homelessness
services should be eligible for housing
there are two kind of big housing
programs
one gets people into kind of rapid
re-housing and the other is long-term
permanent supportive housing
so a lot of the work i was doing on this
assessment was looking at the validity
of the scale
and whether it's accurately assessing
vulnerability in homeless individuals
who are coming
this has a ton of super sensitive
information from hiv aids status
pregnancy status history of domestic
violence and a bunch of really intrusive
information to disclose to a stranger in
an interview
to kind of ask that question but then
zooming back out kind of to the
privileged context
right all of the work on that scale is
fundamentally confined to the analysis
of that project
and there's nothing in the domain of
that analysis to ask the question
should we be assessing vulnerability as
a way to
gatekeep who gets access to housing
resources
there's nothing about that analysis that
asks the question
should housing be a human right it just
allows us to allocate scarce resources
more effectively based on criteria that
we do that we determine to decide like
the moral worthiness
of accessing housing or sometimes even
the cost effectiveness of housing
different kinds of people
so i think often when we focus on the
what's implicated in this specific
algorithm if we take a step back and
look at the broader context in which
we're operating
often the big question is
kind of obfuscated by this specific work
in looking at what an algorithm is doing
and looking at the broader scope gives
us
the real question that we should be
answering the real thing that we should
be working to address
because no amount of working on this
algorithm is going to increase the
amount of housing available in an area
yeah i love that it's disentangling the
the non-technical problems from the
technical problems versus saying
you know i can write code so here's my
hammer everything else is a nail
i think it also means funding
non-technical work
as well and advocating for that um
at your particular company um
i'm saying that very selfishly and
biased isn't as a
primarily non-technical person who's
added a few technical skills
um but i think that's always been
something really really interesting
um too um
to me um i'll
make a i do see in one chat
that somebody said that they're very
worried
adam blackwell again said something that
very worried about the talent sourcing
algorithms
at the tech companies and i think that's
another one where we're materially
impacted
um often uh by kind of the different
ways that we might be hired or not hired
um
and i think that's you know that's i
think one thing
and i'll just re-emphasize this i think
the way that we might feel
worried about a particular algorithm
like materially impacted by it
is the way that so many people feel
impacted by
you know um egregious policing
algorithms jailing algorithms um
anything used by that and to like kind
of hold that feeling close when we think
about the ways other
other algorithms are being deployed as
well
are there any other questions or
comments i don't i don't know um
we could break out into breakout rooms
or we could kind of keep having a little
bit of a casual chat
as um people wind down for the night one
i
i think this ends in about 15 minutes or
so
um i mean i can talk about ethics all
day
but we've kind of gotten through some of
the topics we wanted to address
and then you unmuted so i'll let you
talk
i was just saying yeah i think it said
it for
nine but it's totally fine to
awesome oh i have a question
go for it
so i wrote this in the chat maybe the
question got lost
but it seems like and this is what i've
been sort of alluding to all night
you know how like a company is going to
want to make sure that it doesn't get in
trouble
with anti-discrimination laws like if
you fired all of your black employees
you would end up in a lot of hot water
could we make algorithmic bias something
that could be subject to those laws or
more easily subject to those laws like
the example i gave
with a bank that rips off black
borrowers with inflated interest rates
which is a really common thing that
happens
you know nothing's going to wake up a
drowsy boardroom meeting like the phrase
multi-million dollar class action
lawsuit
what can we do to make it easier for the
law to help us out
so i mean i think this is a large issue
where we talk about kind of
i mean this happens even beyond kind of
ethics but
law and enforcement of law tends to be
one of the last
um kind of accountability steps
when we're talking about everything from
ethics to human rights
um typically a lot of that work gets
really accomplished by
mass organizing and democratic change in
my
in my opinion i'm curious what the
panelists think um
and i also think that some of the most
um effective forms of that are
where you really center some of the
issues that may affect
some of the communities on the
experiences of the community rather than
worrying as much about what um
the board might think even though that
can be an effective organizing technique
if it
if it comes from that first i think it
misses the point
a little bit
thank you that's a really good point
well i think there's an interesting
complicating factor in policing
algorithmic bias especially in terms of
kind of lawsuits
uh that i had in graduate school
his sister he's white and his sister is
white and she has a name
that is traditionally perceived as black
it's a ton of
marketing directed at black women and so
what is what complicates the kind of
bias in the algorithm
analysis is that there's a factuality
gap
where people are perceived in a way by a
computer because of characteristics they
share
but they might not actually share those
on a legal basis
which might mean the group of folks that
are being discriminated against
is not entirely composed of the folks
who like the algorithm is kind of
structurally discriminating against
which weakens the claim
of algorithmic bias because you can show
that some of the people in that group
don't share the characteristics of the
structural bias
and so i think that's an interesting
wrinkle when folks are being
discriminated against based on like very
nuanced characteristics of
often digital profiles rather than
actual legal characteristics which
gives us this like disjointed gap
between where the law
creates protected classes and where the
algorithm
is coding people a certain way based on
characteristics that are generally
shared by groups
so go organize go vote i mean i think
that's the heart of
that's the hardest part of this
discussion that i think you know we all
kind of dance around a little bit when
we're trying to fix things which is
incredible um but that but that
ultimately
you can only fix things insofar as your
culture legal system
organizational structure allow
um as well uh
i will you know kind of i think maybe we
gradually wrap it up now how do people
feel about that
and i think um in the
please feel the free to contact any of
us or
um you know
ping us in in any way i'm on twitter um
i don't know if y'all want to share kind
of your social media's other panelists
i'll put mine in the chat twitter has a
really really active
um kind of chatting about ethics and i
think
any of us would be happy um
you know to come back and chat some more
or hear any of the questions that you
might
might have so
uh ben's internet went out so ben i was
just suggesting we kind of wrap it up
and i gave a couple
uh ways to contact us and just say we
really really enjoyed you all inviting
us so thank you to both sarah and ben
also for organizing this and um
making sure we knew what zoom length to
click on and and
and all the all the good stuff in this
in this world
so yeah thank you and thank all of us
i think this is a really great
conversation i feel like the chat had a
really good like
conversation going too i'm going to try
and like save the chat afterwards
yeah thanks moe emily and charlotte
and nema for for being here and for
talking and giving
a lot of your expertise and perspectives
it's been really interesting
and so important we need more of these
kinds of conversations
all right everyone have a lovely evening
i'll see y'all soon
thank you thanks everyone bye